اذا مشاهدينا الطائرات المسيره باتت وسيله
مفضله للقوات الاوكرانيه للوصول للعمق
الروسي خاصه مع التردد الغربي بدعم كيف
بصواريخ بعيده المدى في اوائل الشهر
الجاري عثر عمال في محطه ضخ نفط في
نوفوسيبوف على قنبله صغيره قال المسؤولون
انها ربما تم اسقاطها من طائره بدون طيار
في وقت لاحق من ذات اليوم نشب حريق في احد
مباني جهاز الامن الفيدرالي اف اس بي وكان
الاحداث في سلسله من الحرائق الغامضه في
جميع انحاء غرب روسيا المحاولات
الاوكرانيه وصلت الى اعماق اكبر داخل
روسيا ففي اواخر الشهر الماضي حاولت مسيره
ضربه محطه ضغط الغاز في كولومنا جنوب شرق
موسكو قبل ذلك في ديسمبر نفضت طائرات دون
طيار من اوكرانيا ضربت ضربات مزدوجه على
قاعده
الهويه التي تضم قاذفه النوويه استراتيجيه
روسيه وخلال عام من الحرب حدثت عده هجمات
بطائرات بدون طيار على اهداف عاليه القيمه
في روسيا منها قواعد عسكريه ومطارات
ومنشات طاقه روسيا تحدثت عن 300 هجمه وقع
ضحيتها 40 قتيلا والقتل اللوم على عاتق
اوكرانيا كيف من جانبها تؤكد دائما على ان
جيشها يعمل فقط في اراضيها ومع ذلك اعترف
مسؤولون بدوري اوكرانيا في بعض الضربات
ومنها تفجير جسر القرن في اكتوبر
[موسيقى]